Good morning, John. I'm headed out on tour next week!
So expect some travel vlogging.
All the shows are all ages and tickets are out at $20.
And somebody asked me on tumblr...
"What is the difference between Hank Green and Hank Green and The Perfect Strangers?"
It's pretty simple.
It's more fun to play music with a band.
And I think it's more fun to listen to music with a band
And so, some of my friends got together and we made a band
But we play the same old Hank Green songs
You'll hear Deathly Hallows and Anglerfish and Strange Charm.
And also some newer songs
Like I Love Science and Oh J.K Rowling and We are All Bat People.
And even some songs we have never before performed live together.
Like We're All 'Gonna Die, which is a song I recently released.
And also, this song, right here.
Surprise!
New Song!
Annie's been Annie for long enough now
she knows what she will and she won't.
Sometimes she's 'gonna be up when you're down.
She's gonna know things that you don't.
And all of the world isn't here just for you.
Annie being Annie doesn't make you less you.
She's got her own baggage
She doesn't need yours, too.
And Annie doesn't need your luck.
Annie doesn't need your worry.
And Annie doesn't hate your guts.
But she does need you to get up and get out of her way!
Do you ever think you're holding her down?
Do you ever even think to ask why?
If you, my friend
are stuck on the ground,
are you terrified that she could fly?
Oh, maybe it's time you took a look at yourself.
Annie's not a trophy you can keep on your shelf.
She's pulling you through life
You're putting her through hell.
Oh, Annie doesn't need your luck.
Annie doesn't need your worry.
And Annie doesn't hate your guts.
But she does need you to get up and get out of her way!
I have to ask, as a friend
a friend to both of you.
So when you hold her close and keep her near.
Is that love or is it fear?
I have to ask because you have to know.
You only get to keep her if you let her go.
Oh let her go
Let her go
'Cause Annie doesn't need your luck!
And Annie doesn't need your worry!
And Annie doesn't hate your guts!
But she just needs you to get up and get out of her way!
Yeah
Oh get up, and get out of her way!
Boy
Get up and get out of her way!
Getting ready to go on tour has involved lots of work.
Ah - I have been quite tired.
And recently I got home from work
And I grabbed some peanut M&Ms
which are my favourite.
And I went and I laid down on my couch.
So, I wake up a half hour later,
and in my mouth is a half eaten M&M.
It was a weird sensation and flavour
but I ate it.
And that's the whole story
I just wanted to tell you that one.
So we have been having some trouble selling as many tickets as we'd like to on tour
This is kind of strange
because like with Kansas,
we're doing amazing!
But in Los Angeles,
where there are more people than Kansas,
we're doing not as well.
So if you are in Austin, San Diego, Los Angeles, Anaheim or San Francisco.
And you're considering maybe coming to the show...
consider it... hard.
I'm super excited about it , I hope you will be too.
For me, concerts have always been something that caused me a lot of anxiety.
Like going to shows always freaked me out.
But also those shows are some of my most precious memories.
We strive to be that for the people that come to our shows.
ANd there's one thing that always kind of bugs me about concerts.
it's when I go I kind of 'wanna know as many of the songs as I can.
'Cause it's more fun when I'm, like, singing along and having a good time.
But you never know what they're 'gonna play.
So, I have put together a limited - but not complete - set list of some of the songs we're 'gonna be playing.
If you would like to know what those are in advance.
As part of my general strategy
to get rid of this conception that you have to be the smartest, most knowledgable person
who knows everything about the band and the act.
No.
Just have a good time!
It's not about looking cool.
And that's it.
Coming to you straight form the mouth that once had an M&M in it for a whole half an hour.
John, I'll see you on Tuesday.